le rugby-club de plaisir n'est plus qu'à
une marche de la montée en fédérale 2 ce
dimanche 7 mais les bleu et jaune ont
réussi leur meilleure prestation de la
saison contre marcq en baroeul pourtant
favori de la rencontre
après une première période convaincante
ponctuée par un 19 à 16 les plaisirs ont
accéléré pour marquer deux essais en
seconde période
ce camp final 31 tél aujourd'hui on
était présent au combat quoi devant on
était bien et on sait très bien trouver
derrière les gars ont fait des super
mouvement ça d'ailleurs été au bout
quasiment à chaque fois donc donc du
coup globalement le collectif ont été
très bons aujourd'hui l'état d'esprit
était top donc je pense que c'est ce que
puisqu'elle fonctionne c'est vraiment
l'âme dit je crois que c'est l'amie qui
a pris mais aujourd'hui avec encore une
fois une bonne application des
lancements de jeu
mais j'insiste lourdement mais c'est
vrai que c'était une énorme envie avec
des garçons qui ont donné le meilleur
d'eux mêmes après cette performance
stratosphérique les plaisirs n'auront
pas le temps de se reposer
le match retour est programmé dès ce
dimanche 14 mai sur le terrain de marcq
en baroeul
le staff s'attend à une opposition plus
coriace il vaut mieux quand même
recevoir sur un match retour forcément
mais eux auront quand la pression parce
qu'ils ont 15 points à remonter et que
c'est à eux à faire le jeu du match
cae a montré quelque chose à sortir un
grand match mais comme nous on n'a pas
du tout l'intention d'y aller
un soleil insolent et ça me fais rien et
regarde à le jouer donc je pense que on
leur donnera du fil à retordre pour ce
match plaisir devrait pouvoir compter
sur un effectif au complet une bonne
nouvelle dans l'optique de réaliser
l'objectif du club fixé en début de
saison la montée en fédérale 2 2 ans
après l'avoir quittée